it was written in such a way that you
know fully realized each character and
gave them all agency and humanity in
themselves and um that was something
that i hadn't really read or seen before
um especially pertaining to immigrant
asian american cinema
let's get straight in there and talk
about the the genesis of this project i
mean it's like it's so clearly it's a
very personal project for you um it's
based loosely based on your own
experiences can you can you talk a
little bit about um how close is it to
your experience what talk about the
inspirations for this project
i'm sure
the film really did start as an exercise
for me in which i was writing down a lot
of memories that i have from childhood
um
i i had been wanting to make this film
for a while
but never really knew how to how to do
it and how to start but
i was inspired by um this writer named
willa cather who said that her work
started when she started to
uh remember when she stopped trying to
admire and and uh
follow the lead of other writers and she
just started to look into her own
experiences
so one day in the library here where i
live i just sat down and i started to
write all these memories
and as i got to around 80
memories i started to see the shape of
the story
in which a family arrives at a mobile
home
in the middle of nowhere in arkansas and
the mother had no idea that the father
would
take the family there
and that really comes from my true true
life
and kind of ends with a family gathering
minari together at a patch where the
grandmother has planted
this plant from korea
and that's something that came from real
life as well
so
once i had these memories down i i saw
uh several themes coming out and also
the shape of a story in which each
character could really have
uh some sort of arc and
um and then i just got busy uh with that
script i i got to work with it and it
came out pretty quickly i gotta say
um it felt like something that i had
just been sitting on and chewing over
all my life so
once i started to really write it it
just flowed out and um it's almost a
blur how that happened
um can you tell me a little bit more
about the writing process i mean
obviously as the film is inspired by
your own childhood presumably the
character of david the little boy is a
character that you kind of related to
but during the writing process did you
find yourself identifying with other
characters more as well so for example
jacob was that was it sort of an
interesting way to
get to know your own parents a little
bit more perhaps
oh definitely um i
as i started to write i just thought
it's this story is not going to work as
a family portrait if
i'm only entering into it at the
at the level of david if if that's all
all that i see myself in
um i i kind of felt like every single
person in the family needs to have some
sort of agency and needs to have
their own humanity and
the only way that i
knew i could do that was if i injected
my own
thoughts and feelings and
my own experiences into each of the
characters
and naturally i gravitated a lot to uh
jacob played by stephen
and the idea of a man who is exactly my
age
and has children who are the age of of
my daughter uh and uh out to start a new
life somewhere doing something that many
might seem
many might say is crazy and and that's
kind of what i felt i was doing with
trying to pursue
becoming a filmmaker
um so i i identified a lot with jacob um
but also i identified with a lot of the
other characters as well even even crazy
paul you know i see myself in that guy
quite a lot as well um
so yeah it was quite a joy to work on
this script and to explore each each
person i think uh dostoevsky when he
talks about his novels he he says that
he really does that with each character
that he can't say that he identifies
with just a single one but uh he's
peppered through all of them and that's
something that i hope to do with this
i'm just going to pick up on one thing
what what a view is in crazy paul
because it seems quite unlikely that uh
you don't you don't come across as crazy
pull to me
um i well i um
i i think i
i gravitate to the idea of looking at
the world in a more magical way in in
ways that are not just surface level and
not just um
rational
but
um really seeing
uh
you know
the spirit and everything um and that's
something that i i i had a lot of fun
writing this and and
uh having that sort of fanciful sort of
uh approach to to looking at the world
stephen i mean this film is it's based
on
lee's life but loosely based on it but
as a as a korean american who was born
in south korea but raised in america did
you i mean presumably you found there
was a connection for you um can you talk
a little bit about that and
how you felt when you read the first
read the material
yeah um
the
you know what ring really true for me um
when i read the script the first time
was um
just how much it was
kind of unhindered by
any outside um gaze
uh it really didn't need to define
itself
by juxtaposing itself to something else
but it was just really like a true and
honest telling of a perspective that i
deeply can identify with and um
uh you know in connecting with isaac
about it the thing that
you know at least personally for me that
i think um
is kind of the start of
the journey of at least jacob
uh that i identify with that perhaps
isaac might as well is is in some ways a
theme of isolation
um uh just a just just trying to make
your own way um just apart from the
systems that you you know and um how
how kind
of how complex that idea is how how you
might drag your family with you while
you're doing that but also there's such
a distinct like
natural urge to want to create something
like that and uh that tension between
your ego and um kind of the real
relational life that you live is is is a
tough one and so um yeah there was there
was just so much there you know even
on very basic
uh
points just being able to see a
representation of our of our parents
generation uh and the story that they
lived um not just in a
memory or um from even our own gays but
rather it was written in such a way that
you know fully realized each character
and gave them all agency and humanity in
themselves and um that was something
that i hadn't really read or seen before
um especially pertaining to immigrant
asian american cinema
a lot of the time i think you know uh
you're seeing something that tries to
understand your parents from your point
of view and that's always in some ways
kind of
not the full picture
um
and uh yeah it was really cool to play
uh jacob because it was it felt free to
to show that
um you mentioned you know your parents
generation did the process of making
this film and inhabiting this character
do you think it gave you a sort of a new
a fresh insight into you know your
parents and and that generation what
would you say you took away from it
yeah i mean i took away a lot um i think
you know the the one of the largest
initial hurdles was what i was kind of
touching on earlier of just
um
the image that i had created of my
parents generation and um
and
how strong and powerful that was
internally for me and how that kind of
that perception kind of coded the view
of how i always looked at them as well
and so it was that first initial like
hurdle to overcome which was you know
this is not an idea of what you think
your parents are you have to really
deeply understand um what was happening
and i think you know as a parent myself
um
you know you make a lot of those
connections i think it's a classic thing
of just like understanding your parents
when you have your own children
so the timing was really interesting for
me
um
but
yeah i think the largest thing that i'm
still unpacking is
um
you know i we are i am my father's son
you know i am my father um
there's just a
there's that connection there's that
deep humanity uh we lived in different
times under different circumstances
doing different things but
um you know personally for me
especially as an actor
and like isaac said as a filmmaker
and as asian americans
we're kind of working in a space that is
not traditional for uh
at least myself or people like us and so
um it feels new it feels
um like each step
doesn't really have a road map
uh in front of it and um in that way i
really felt a deep connection to kind of
the the charge that i think my father
probably had as well
[Music]
[Music]
you